ça se vend bien combien par jour j'ai
pas une trentaine 40 c'est bien ce
travail au total ça fait quoi on sait
pas en fait beaucoup il s'est plaint à
ce qu'on avait pu en fait c'est rare que
les écrivains vendre les bons même c'est
un truc qu'on est en train de mettre au
point ils sont super league ouais c'est
que les actifs en voie de vendeurs et de
systématiser ce avec tous les auteurs
alors la grosse tête c'est vrai ouais
vraiment parce que même pour les
vendeurs c'est bien de ça ils savent
qu'ils ont
fait c'est vrai que dans ce livre
c'est une histoire de deux filets
piloselle son enfant du tour eiffel
fouet le son des toits se rencontrent
ras le bol des coups tu dis j'en ai font
plein de trucs corps ouais
el bez elle se défend s'est tue des gens
qui peuvent à un geste aura vécu j'ai
jamais tué personne je suis défense pas
et auquel tu dois pas trop avant sus
pour le bouquin quoi oui c'est une
oeuvre de fiction l'a complètement non
pour
doute eu des hautois union
geipan taille 1 1 c'est bien quand même
fou fou d'avoir ça va faire un petit
accident visuel tu vois
en afrique berceau en titre a fait un
bon petit train des fortes en marketing
on réfléchit hyper dur là-dessus ouais
bon va devenir dont je proviens tt ou à
lyon xi vous jeter sur des pentes et je
suis rien du tout c'est pas ton van en
dépendent non c'est parce que tu étais
sur les pandas géants du quartier là et
puis jeu suivant je fais bien moindre tu
te rennais
bah ouais je buvais des coupes je
discutais de trucs et où je
réfléchissais
réunis à paris j'ai rencontré florent et
puis on a fait des soins pas qu'à
rentrer quelques morceaux l'éditeur
ouais mais ça lui qui t'a dit décrivant
tu avais envie d'écrire non j'avais déjà
écrit en maintenant j'ai rencontré way
et après on a fait tous ensemble ouais
ça raconte moi un peu le bouquet
numérique du mal à imaginer un client
j'ai pas les gens ils connaissent une
magie tout cela aux échos laissent d'eau
donc c'est pas bien en fait commencé à
ce qu'on avait en tant que connaissent
d'autres causes entre quoi bon bouche à
oreille qu'il ya des trucs comme après
c'est une chez pas
des gens alors c'est des gens qui
arrivent et disent je restais voilà
alors des fois on voit donc des gens
hyper bien pas des patinoires candidats
classés tour
donc quoi s'il ya une grande fille et
une petite fille enfin plus petit quoi
elle dit nein de l'étape 1 l'hôtel films
pornos et se rencontrent ils viennent de
faire des embrouilles in and aliens tué
sa colocataire à l'hôtel et vient de
tuer
je me rappelle plus
elle vient de tuer quelqu'un qui avait
fait du mal un copain à laborde elles
sont toutes là et puis elles se sont
plutôt copina s'entendent vraiment super
bien et puis après ils font un grand
coup en france quoi faire quand il faut
pas en fait un road movie j'ai fait ça
toi non non non non j'ai du super
tranquille
et ici comment ça se passe alors c'est
bien payé d'être vendeur la normale ce
pays normal comme tender genre quand
même c'est pas pour me stresser preuve
je travaille seul et in et 7 nuls sont
serrés mais travaille aussi avec ever ça
dépend des jours en vérité
jusqu'à minuit des fois mais c'est un
boulot vendeur c'est normal rien à dire
que ça sent déjà fait pour supporter
toute la journée bref australe ait à 101
c est ce qu une tout le monde sont
commises par l école quelqu'un voudra
dire que pas de toi qu'est ce que tu
fais tu dissuade u10 u11
et u10 collège il explique ce passage
tous les atouts jeunes amènent ici après
ce disque outre mieux quoi encore les
gens qui est des gens ne peuvent pas
venir et surtout pas qu'on
non c'est mon travail normal 300 ouais
c'est cher [ __ ] 56 france maintien de
postes première édition prend une
première dépêche heures je prends quand
même par beau gain de 4,4
déjà tu fait au moins 120 vols par jour
ouais à la fin je mettrai ça par jour
quand on aura tous tout récupérer les
souhaits du fondeur distribuera quoi
mais d'après choix arrêté de travailler
[Musique]
bon ben on va y aller loin tu vas au
soir
je sais pas je travaille super car ils
se posent sur la cale à stravinsky les
onze joueurs quoi vraiment l'impression
pas où tu vas après cela ce qui est des
gens il passa près par les fermetures
puis je repars avec eux quoi se chercher
tu es une star oui chaque soir dans le
quartier
à lyon il est retombé fois moins cher
temps de se lancer bien ses parents
t'ont pendant
dix ans n'occupe pas trop
ça les voisins de tes parents tu écris
ce genre de bouquin ni maison ni tes
parents voulaient pas
c'est leur faute de la penske ont bien
ouais
tu crois que tu as mal dormi non mais
aussi bien me sentir super contente d'en
faire un autre ouais enfin l'otan
attaquait la jet set 1-6 la juhel non
j'ai pas que les gars sont tus pour les
bouquins à tous
il ya beaucoup de plantes à pas dans le
bocal que jamais fait ça toi oh non non
au niveau 10 décédé en quoi
alors qu'est ce tu fais soit pas que les
garçons et les filles n'ont plus vu
personne un peu du coup je discute quoi
va pas sans ambition tout sexuellement
comment tu fais là bas je m'en passe et
j'en ai plein fouet comme sa maman
on peut s'en passer ouais après faire du
sport voilà la piscine est souvent
courir et ça ça aide à faire passer le
manque de sexe même vachement paris des
gens et font plein de sexe en fait je
m'en tire aussi bien ouais si j'en garde
sont pas mieux que toi tu veux dire non
bon tu avais je suis enrhumé belges
fassent rapidement
la fièvre est tous là ça se voit
très malade bon ben ça lui donne jamais
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu